a grandes rasgos Cuál es el panorama en
Perú y qué relación tiene con la crisis
climática Buenas noches Paola sí
efectivamente los casos de dengue este
año se han incrementado En comparación
con los últimos quince años Estamos
hablando de más de
1992 mil casos en el Perú
y sí hay una relación muy estrecha con
el tema del cambio climático porque en
nuestro país desde el año pasado
inicios de este año se han reportado
lluvias sobre todo en el norte en el
norte de nuestro país como piura tumbes
lambayeque se han registrado
inundaciones y todo este escenario ha
sido propicio para la reproducción del
mosquito transmisor del dengue no que es
el aedes egipti No
ahora estos casos de alguna manera se
han disparado también porque
a raíz de estas lluvias no solo digamos
se ha establecido todo este escenario de
que permite la reproducción de este
mosquito si nota que también han
colapsado en varias regiones los
sistemas de drenaje de agua potable y
eso todavía ha hecho que las personas
vayan a recurrir digamos al
almacenamiento de agua no y todo esta
situación además ha impactado en los
servicios de salud porque la
infraestructura también ha colapsado y
con ello este la atención a los
pacientes que hacen infectado con con
por el dengue no precisamente le
pregunto por esto por la gestión de la
situación Qué medidas no Se tomaron para
prevenir el escenario actual y que se
puede hacer ahora
Bueno ya se sabía desde finales del año
pasado lo que podría ocurrir por el tema
de las lluvias y de las inundaciones
Lamentablemente desde el gobierno
peruano específicamente desde el
Ministerio de salud ha habido una
reacción tardía en el país han empezado
digamos a realizar fumigaciones en
varias regiones sobre todo en el norte
pero lamentablemente estas fumigaciones
principalmente acaban con los mosquitos
adultos no entonces en el dengue no
acaban digamos con las larvas y estas
larvas cerca de siete nueve días Ya se
convierten en mosquitos adultos y
justamente estos son los el transmisor
de la enfermedad y ahora con el tema del
cambio climático también este ciclo
digamos de de crecimiento se reduce no
entonces hay una disminución de días
para para el desarrollo del mosquito
bueno y Por ende para que transmita la
enfermedad y bueno este ha habido una
mala gestión que incluso este llevó a la
renuncia de la ministra de salud y
actualmente
es bueno Siguen con las campañas de
prevención ahora ha disminuido un poco
digamos la cantidad de contagios pero
Igualmente igual el el pico es alto y
bueno se están haciendo se están
destinando presupuestos para otro tipo
de campañas no pero sí eso ha sido ya
algo tardío y creo que sí se le debería
poner foco porque como también
mencionaste el inicio de la introducción
ya estábamos en un contexto de fenómeno
del niño anunciado no y es probable que
en los próximos meses este impacten
nuestro país y nuevamente este ciclo se
vuelva a repetir